I get the impression that he tries to
see a whole lot of variations tries to
memorize and they spend a lot of energy
before the game would you advise such an
approach in general it's it's useful to
spend some some time on it before before
the game like how much energy you should
use I don't know like these days like
for me it's probably like at most half
an hour that I would spend with it for
before a game a few years ago maybe a
little bit more but now I don't know I
cannot bring myself to like sitting for
hours and hours memorizing stuff but
thank you for going to play a certain
certain land especially than something
that you don't know in and out and you
don't think you can play if I feel yeah
you can remember that stuff